in the lobby of Ramsey solutions will
and Kelly are with us hey guys how are
you
we're good hey you did better than I
deserve better than others or were you
guys from Wasilla Alaska ah very nice my
wife Sharon and I were through there
this summer as we headed up to Denali on
a trip we were on very nice and you have
a famous resident don't you yeah but her
gate to her house was really not
impressive just kind of like a wooden
gate well I don't think it impresses
many as people up there either so I
don't think she spends a lot of time
there anymore either than what I thought
that's what I hear
well I good to have you guys so you're
here all the way from Alaska and you use
this you used coming to Tennessee as
your excuse to do your debt-free scream
right
we did we did I love it how much of you
paid off we pit up two hundred fifty
four thousand in eight years and two
months Wow and range of income during
that time between fifty four thousand
and two hundred thousand okay there's a
little spread so whose career took off
here well that would be his yeah my
average income was about one hundred and
twelve and then I got to get big pay
raise here about last year what do you
do I'm a pilot oh it was a so is
everybody else in Alaska oh my gosh
there's people more pilot's license and
driver's license I believe yeah it's
kind of the way to get around up there
yeah apparently yeah what is the saying
you can only go to Juneau by air be born
there or by water that's it there's no
rose yeah so very cool hey guys well
congratulations so you're eight years
two and 54-thousand I'm guessing this is
your house it was house off your house
and your student loans yeah Wow
how old are you two well I am 31 I'm 37
I'm looking at weird people yeah you
paid for house we didn't realize how
weird we were until we kind of got close
to the end people start looking at you
weird yeah you walk different so what's
this house worth in Wasilla Alaska
I felt like 235 okay very cool and how
much of the 254 was too
loan debt thirty thirty-five thousand
okay very cool well congratulations you
guys how's it feel I mean you're I've at
forty you don't have a freaking house
baby you're so weird how does it feel
it's awesome it's still sinking in the
bank account now that the money's not
going towards the mortgage is slowly
increasing and it's only been since July
so we're like oh wow it's not a money in
her account
well while there was still grass in the
backyard did you take your feet off your
feet off your shoes off and walk around
and let your feet feel the grass did you
owned we did I love it very cool that's
fun well congratulations you guys so
what started all of this eight years ago
well Alaska Airlines announced a
furlough and I was in the number both
times they announced it and so I decided
well we decided we didn't want to ever
be in a position again where we maybe
had to Oh a bunch of money and had no
income mm-hmm and so we started down the
Financial Peace University and no one
why should we read the book we didn't do
that okay
Total Money Makeover financial piece
okay and so you still fly for them mmm
very cool good very good
yeah that jump in income was because he
made captain last year ah there it is
okay very nice well congratulations well
that makes it a little easier to get to
Tennessee you probably got a little
airline deal there yeah yeah not bad
still along that gun flight without a
doubt our series of them yes we were we
were up for 48 hours traveling all night
and all day
wow wow you get little jet lag hopefully
you can get to enjoy Nashville while
you're here so I you just said we're not
going to but we're going we're not going
to live like this we're not going to
have this risk and you grab the Total
Money Makeover book and you plow into it
how long have y'all been married I will
be coming up on 12 years in January okay
so you'd been married three or four
years before you started this right yeah
but uh so he comes in and says hey this
furlough is coming I want us to buckle
down and get this stuff paid off and
what did you say Kelly um well we got
the call while we were camping and we
both kind of gave a look of like oh my
gosh
we just bought a hell
and what are we gonna do for our job um
so I've always been the saver that I
will knack for that growing up mm-hmm
and I have come from five sisters and
two brothers and my sisters love to shop
and I was not that kind of person and so
it wasn't hard at all for me to go sure
let's do this okay cool well good for
you guys I'm proud of you very fun and
thank you for coming all the way to
Tennessee to do your debt-free scream
that's very neat I I told will and asked
like we should go
could you go yell in the lobby we had to
make an occasion of it it's like well I
don't okay 48 hours later it's fun and
then when I found that you had to apply
I was like oh we're not gonna get picked
was a good idea anyways oh we pick
everybody as long as they're doing the
stuff we teach you know you're still
using a credit card we're not going to a
debt-free screen and that kind of stuff
but it's just a matter of getting in the
queue because there's a bit of a
six-week wait list these days but well
we're glad you're here very cool and
congratulations very very proud of you
well we've got a copy of Chris Hogan's
retire inspired book and that's the next
chapter in your story has become very
wealthy and very outrageously generous
live like no one else seen you have so
now you're ready to live and give like
no one else and all in your 30s just
amazing so proud of y'all very well done
England there well thanks alright it's
will and Kelly from Alaska two hundred
and fifty four thousand dollars paid off
that includes their house shut up in
eight years making fifty four all the
way to two hundred count it down let's
hear a debt free scream three two one
one
I love it boom well done you two
very well done hey that's how life works
right there man that's absolutely
awesome very cool
hey 31 37 years old in the house payment
what are you doing I'm talking to you
what are you doing just kind of coasting
along thinking one of these two vile
creatures that are running for president
is going to fix your life you're gonna
have a long life if you wait on
Washington fix your life your life's
gonna keep sucking I'll tell you that
seriously what are you doing they just
paid off their house I know what they're
done what are you doing there's no
reason you can't hey it's a choice all
you gotta do is just choose I'm gonna
live different I'm not gonna be like
everyone else I'm gonna make some
different decisions that's all you got
to do it's not any harder than that you
got to be getting with it that's simple
simple hey guys thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
you